hi my name is David dang I'm a hair
stylist and tri colleges to have even
four men come to the shoot today to
speak about the potential of hair loss
or the subject of hair loss is huge
so why do you think that you have hair
loss my dad is bald
my brother's hairline is worse than
LeBrons oh oh like oh I I think I'm next
prior to this I had a top nut and then I
started to realize that my hair looked
like it was starting to like thin
trakula pichia is one people like braid
their hair
it breaks the follicles I feel like at
one point someone talked about like a
widow's peak and if you had that then it
meant you were gonna lose your hair and
that freaked me out for a minute which I
don't think is true when the guys see
their hairline kind of go back a little
bit more that's natural mmm so you have
your hairline received just a little bit
my oldest brother has a little bit of
fitting here because of that I'm like
well maybe yeah I would then out and he
started sort of thinning at my age now
the general age of someone losing hair
that I have experienced right is between
the age of 20 right to like 30 maybe
even early 30s
as far as I see here it's perfect and if
I'm running my hands through it it's
perfect do you have medium to coarse
hair and then your hairline the only
areas of concern I can always see is
like a little patch right here and
that's probably again breakage I really
don't see any areas of concern okay cool
there you go yeah I can't wait very word
that you can be like looking at this is
it six watts get ready your hairline is
healthy okay
which is great your natural dreads are
awesome I don't see a lot a lot of
concerns here but I do see slight
concern in the best light that's what I
thought yeah yeah I'm going to have to
hair scrub em so minoxidil and minoxidil
basically is it helps to block any extra
hormones which causes the hair loss
suffocation in the dermal layers I don't
really see any areas of concern
haha I'm going to be sick today oh my
god I could see how you probably would
think in this in the hairline because
your hair is fine and it's lighter right
so you could see right through your
scalp right I feel like this is so
important especially like guys don't
talk about Beauty much we don't do a lot
of accessorizing typically so this is
one of the main features of our presence
so that's why I think we put so much
faith in it to stay there forever
because like it's one of the only things
we do do like decide how we look so
we'll talk about your hair wardrobe what
does that look like a hair wardrobe yeah
I mean by hair wardrobe a little tie
with little Berets little little what
are they Bratz the Beretta brats I don't
know wow yeah those little metal
fasteners haha those dolls would be
possible for that